DNA is a chemical found in the center of  cells and it carries instructions for  the development and function of all  living things  it is a set of blueprints containing the  instructions needed to build cells a  gene is a section of DNA and tells the  cells how to produce certain things such  as the proteins which give us I color  the shape of DNA is a double helix two  strands and twined together and  connected with rungs like a twisted  ladder the sides of the helix are made  of alternating groups of sugar and  phosphate  attached to each sugar is one of four  bases adenine cytosine guanine or  thymine the helix strands are held  together by bonds between these bases  and the ordering of bases is important  because it translates to what the  instructions say and makes each of us  unique  Oh  Oh